Charlottesville's leaders voted to drape  the city statues of robert e lee and  Stonewall Jackson and black fabric after  chaos broke out during a city council  meeting last night the people screams  enchanted angry about how the city  handled the violent white supremacist  rally ten days ago now please remove  several people from that meeting  councillors scrapped the rest of the  agenda and agreed to hear three hundred  people speak they later voted to cover  the Confederate statues to represent the  city's mourning of Heather hire she was  killed when an alleged white supremacist  drove into a crowd of counter protesters  during the rally